we have a question from our store in
Stockholm and they want to know if you
have any tips on how to write better
dialogue and if you have like some
authors that are favorites yeah reading
dialogue is something that Hollywood
really helped me with you know when you
when you write a script it has a
different format it's easily researched
if any of you are interested just by any
good reference book on screenwriting and
you'll see the the format and the
dialogue is presented in blocks with
much narrower margins and an experienced
screenwriter as I discovered when I went
to Hollywood in in 85 and 86 to work on
Twilight Zone they don't even read the
dialogue they just look through and if
they see large blocks of dialogue
someone giving a long speech they know
it's not going to work this is not
Shakespeare well we want characters
delivering soliloquies for two pages
they want to see short dialogue a line
or two back and forth back and forth
back and forth and that's the kind of
dialogue that attempts to work the other
key to dialogue is reading it aloud so I
like I'm about to give a reading now
they'll be doing that here when you read
your work aloud you you you hear the
speeches that work the speeches that
doesn't work you can get a good feeling
for that so something sometimes looks
good on a page where you actually try to
deliver the line and it it stumbles